hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions on my
Game of Thrones videos this weekend fun
fact I actually found out that there's
like a YouTube limit on the amount of
replies that you can do on a single
comment everybody went so crazy after
that finale I guess YouTube just broke
thank you everyone that's been
submitting subtitle corrections to I'll
explain at the end of the video if you
want to do that if you see like an error
in the subtitles and you want to correct
it it's actually really easy to do so
here we go just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet on two
questions starting with actually on
Twitter actually pulled a couple
questions off a Twitter
Zubair asks which one would you read
first or watch first
if both season six and the winds of
winter come out at the same time I would
actually I would probably just read them
in the order that they come out I don't
wait for stuff like I just I consume
media as it's released I can understand
the desire to hold off on certain things
like if you wait to watch something but
if I'm gonna make a video about
something and a book will help give
context to that video that I need to
read it also I just I really don't like
waiting for stuff so there's that too
I'm kind of impatient next question
pitch car asks Daario was very
persistent on going along with Jorah
are you worried he might be jealous and
try to get rid of Jorah no I think
there's a certain camaraderie between
them I mean they're they're both kind of
self swords they're both really smart
people who are dedicated to Daenerys so
if nothing else then that will bring
them together they want to help her
Jorah probably understands that he's
never gonna be with Daenerys but he has
this love for her that transcends
physical love he's what you would call a
true believer that's what his whole
speech to Tyrion whenever they were
traveling together was about about true
faith so I'm just expecting total bro
road trip at least one episode of them
traveling together before they find
Daenerys I don't think it'll be right
away
next question Thomas asks what is the
connection between dragon glass and
Valyrian steel well so obsidian that
that's what dragon glass is that's
basically volcanic rock that has cooled
Valyrian steel is tempered metal
surprise surprise being that they both
have very similar properties we're
probably gonna find out on the show or
in the books that you Forge Valyrian
steel by combining it with obsidian and
tempering it with dragon fire
that just an easy slam-dunk for both the
books and the show because you have
essentially what is like a dragon glass
factory on Dragonstone stan has set
himself on the show
it's full of dragonglass Daenerys might
feel compelled to return there at some
point on her journey to Westeros and use
it as like a base of operations when it
comes time to fight the White Walkers
they could turn it into a giant Forge
for making more Valyrian steel the
problem is is that nobody in the books
that we know about and nobody on the
show knows the connection between
obsidian and Valyrian steel
when way around that would be for
Samwell to find something when he's at
the Citadel that feels like an easy
thing to give his character he's like
the character that figures things out
because he reads lots of books so do not
be surprised if in season 7 you see them
figure out how to make more Valyrian
steel and start doing that using
Daenerys dragons next question
Mariano asks what are your thoughts on
where benjin is is he alive or dead well
you know george RR martin leaves it a
lot more open-ended than the show does
the show hasn't mentioned of it all
barely so I think he's still alive and I
think he'll resurface as part of bran
story I know a lot of people are
wondering if he might be cold hands in
the books that character hasn't shown up
on the show but it's implied that cold
hands is much more ancient than benjin
could be so I don't think that cold
hands is benjin but yeah he probably is
alive and he'll probably come back with
white Walker Intel and a lot of people
are wondering if he might be the night's
king here like he might have been
co-opted by the White Walkers if that
were true then they would probably go
further to make this night's King
character look more like Joseph Mali
look like the actor that plays benjin so
I don't think this is benjin next
question Anthony asks if aria wears a
new face would she be able to see with
it do you think that that would persuade
her to stop being aria and become no one
no I I think that she's always gonna be
Arya Stark I think that at some point
she'll regain her sight but then she'll
backtrack again jaqen did imply that all
manner of unusual things could happen
when a girl puts on another face as if
he was trying to say that aria trying to
use the face that she used is what made
her blind but I think there's a magical
component to it that she just doesn't
know about yet just wearing the face
itself is just just a mask it it doesn't
change anything about her magically the
the magic part
is a different technique that jacket
just hasn't taught her yet next question
popcorn asks the only thing that went
through my head when ilaria kiss
Marcella was well she's dead but yeah
that could be that Marcella dying could
be the thing that makes Jamie become a
terrible person again sir she looks like
she backtracked and she's gonna be
terrible in season six the same thing
could happen to Jamie like Jamie's time
with Brienne made him want to be a
better person he tried it this happens
in erases all the progress he's made and
he just turns into a terrible person
just like Cersei thematically that would
kind of fit with what's going on with
Aria like you try to be this new person
but you can never escape the person that
you really are
next question blind samurai asks you
know what they need Valyrian steel
bullets that's actually that's an
interesting idea but I think an
aerosolized version of Valyrian steel
would work even better like turning into
like a gas bomb the problem with using
projectile Valyrian steel weapons is
that you lose the Valyrian steel the
minute you fire it from a gun or a bow
so it's like a one-time-only kind of
thing if you have a giant army of white
walkers and whites it'd make more sense
to use an area of effect weapon like a
giant gas bomb some of you have asked
about wildfire like is wildfire
effective against the white walkers it
looks like normal fire isn't because
that white Walker in episode 8 walked
right through it without giving it a
second thought there's just there like a
couple weapons on the show that they've
been pointing to as being very important
dragon related I think those will be
effective against white walkers anything
to do with dragons or volcanoes next
question Remmy asks when will Game of
Thrones start shooting will winds of
winter be released before season six
well Game of Thrones typically starts
shooting sometime around whatever
comic-con happens like late June early
July that's why all the actors aren't
always able to come to comic-con
the earliest estimates for winds of
winter is on or abouts the time season
six gets ready to come out
that's if there aren't any major delays
or Georgia or Martin doesn't run into
any problems he hasn't made any promises
he hasn't said that that's just people
guessing at how fast he writes and how
much material is left to cover he's not
gonna say it's ready to come out until
he submits his final manuscript for the
final material to his editor so when his
editor decides that it does
need any more editing and they can start
printing copies then they'll have a date
next question zou asks can you give a
prediction on brand well I think what's
gonna happen with bran is is that he
will have information on the White
Walkers that he gets via flashbacks his
story right now is almost exclusive to
what's going on with the war for the
dawn and there's a lot of other things
happening on the show so they just
weren't quite ready to go that far that
fast they still want to withhold a lot
of that information from the audience
and when you have a character that has
that much power over nature and can see
across time and space it just throws the
narrative off but I'd really like to see
is bran send visions to the other
characters like if Daenerys a vision of
what she needs to do in the way that the
three-eyed Raven gave visions to bran
next question err Finch asks so as the
show caught up completely with the books
now no actually it is not there are a
lot of things that they skipped in the
books that they might go back to in
season 6 there's a lot of people
theorizing that they skipped Lady
Stoneheart which actually happened a
while ago in the books so that when they
do it on the show it'll be a bigger WTF
so they might give some of the Lady
Stoneheart Ark to a different character
some other really big examples are your
own Greyjoy in the Kingsmoot they skip
that all together so there are bits and
pieces and details that are really
important to what's happening in the war
for the dawn that they just didn't have
time for characters that they had to cut
out that they could always include in
slightly different ways in future
seasons and remember wins the winners
gonna come out next year Dan and Dave
are gonna read that so they could
incorporate some winds of winter stuff
into season seven and that's assuming
that George R Martin hasn't let them
read any of his work prints from wins a
winner right now like any unfinished
chapters thank you so much though
everyone for so many questions these are
always a ton of fun to do and yes I will
keep doing Q&A videos but for those
asking which books to start reading now
here a couple recommendations if you
haven't read anything yet just start
with the first book by the time you get
through all five books in the next nine
months or so wins a winner will be out
and Season six will start if you've
already read all the main novels or you
don't care about them check out the side
stories you know just go to a George RR
Martin's author page on Amazon there's
the rogue prince the princess and the
Queen those two stories comprised the
dance of the Dragons storyline that
Shireen was reading to serve Davos in
episode
this October they're re-releasing the
dunk and egg trilogy in combined format
like all three books jammed into one
giant book that's all about the early
life of Aegon v that's where the name
egg comes from egg as in Aegon if you
haven't checked it out either world of
Ice and Fire is a lot of fun too there's
a lot more illustrations in that book
it's mostly historical it's like a
combination of a bunch of stuff from the
wiki speaking of books congratulations
to my giveaway winners
Anthony Barnes you win the signed copy
of a feast for crows and stalking self I
love that name you win the Amazon gift
card both of you be sure to message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact info my next game of
Thrones bonus video should post thursday
or friday that's gonna be an explainer
for all the resurrections that have
happened on the show between the red god
and the great other there's just like so
much Game of Thrones stuff to get
through that I'm kind of behind on my
other videos so I'm trying to catch up
on everything this week those of you
that want to help out with subtitles
it's really simple if you see an error
in the subtitles just go in through the
subtitle menu here you select add
captions and it'll take you to this menu
where you can edit specific portions of
the existing subtitle so it's really
simple you don't have to make like
completely new subtitles thank you
everyone in advance if you want to help
out with this in case you haven't seen
it yet I just posted my season six
predictions you can click here to watch
that and you can click here for my
finale video thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
you